TO MEASURE OR PROGRESS IN THIS
FIRST ANNIVERSARY OF FERGUSON WE
TURN TO MIKE YARD FOR OUR
SEGMENT
LOOK HOW FAR WE HAVE COME.
>> I HAVE A DREAM.
>> WE ARE EQUAL IN THE EYES OF
GOD.
>> GOD BLESS THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
>> Larry: VERY NICE.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, MIKE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
SO NICE.
>> Larry: THERE HAS BEEN SOME
GOOD.
SOME BAD.
HOW FAR HAVE WE COME?
>> WE'RE [BEEP], LARRY.
[LAUGHING]
>> Larry: OKAY.
GIVE ME -- WELL, I KNOW IT
LOOKS BAD.
IT HAS TO BE BETTER THAN LAST
YEAR.
>> YOU KNOW HOW SO FAR WE HAVE
COME, LARRY.
YOU TAKE ALL OF THE MEDIA
ATTENTION.
THE DOJ REPORTS, THE WHITE
OFFICERS, THE OFFICERS FIRED OR
CHARGED, FACTOR IN THE OTHER
BLACK LIVES TAKEN THIS YEAR.
THE OFFICERS THAT DID GET OFF
AND THE MEDIA FATIGUE AND WE
HAVE COME ABOUT THIS FAR.
THAT'S IT.
>> Larry: THAT'S NOT A VERY BIG
DISTANCE.
>> NO, IT'S NOT, LARRY.
NOT AT ALL.
IT'S A DISTANCE THE AIR MOVES
WHEN A BABY BIRD FLAPS IT'S
WINGS.
>> Larry: LOOK ON THE BRIGHT
SIDE THE BABY BIRD WILL FLY.
>> YOU DIDN'T LET ME FINISH.
WHEN A BABY BIRD FLAPS ITS WINGS
AFTER IT'S TOSSED OUT OF THE
NEST TOO SOON AND PLUMMETS TO
IT'S DEATH.
THAT'S HOW FAR.
>> Larry: THAT'S SAD.
>> WE HAVE PROGRESSED THE SAME
DISTANCE OF A CATERPILLAR.
>> Larry: CATERPILLARS TURN INTO
BUTTERFLIES.
>> WHOSE LEGS WERE CUT OFF BY
A SICK TEENAGER.
WE'RE AN ANCIENT GREEK MARATHON
RUNNER INCHES FROM THE FINISH
LINE.
AT LEAST WE'RE INCH FROM THE
FINISH LINE.
>> THE FINISH LINE IS IN POMPEI
>> BUT IF THEY'RE GREEK, ISN'T
POMPEI IN ITALY?
>> IT'S A MARATHON, LARRY!
IT'S A LONG RUN.
>> Larry: I UNDERSTAND.
>> WE TRAVELED THE SAME
DISTANCE AS A CHILD'S WISH WHEN
THE WISH IS TO EAT ICE CREAM FOR
BREAKFAST, LARRY.
>> Larry: THAT MAKES NO SENSE.
>> I CAN'T THINK ANYMORE, LARRY.
I HAVE FERGUSON FATIGUE, LARRY
. I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE OVER.
YOU THINK MY BRAIN CAN KEEP
COMING UP WITH RACIAL INJUSTICE
METAPHORS FOR YOUR SHOW.
IT'S EXHAUSTING, BROTHER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Larry: OKAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE CLAPPING
FOR MY STUPID SHOW.
>> I DON'T KNOW EITHER.
Larry: MIKE, I WOULDN'T OF
ASKED YOU TO REPORT ON FERGUSON
IF I KNEW IT TROUBLED YOU SO
MUCH.
>> IT'S OKAY.
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
I'M BETTER NOW.
YOU KNOW, LARRY.
IT'S THIS SITUATION LIKE A
BUCKET OF RAIN DANCE.
>> Larry: OKAY.
MIKE YARD,  EVERYBODY.
>> LIKE A DIRTY BOWLING ALLEY